في العراق وضمان امن الطاقه والغذاء ابرز
ملفات قمه بغداد الاردن هذه القمه بمشاركه
فرنسا وعدد من الدول في اجنده القمه تتصدر
اولويات الامن في المنطقه من بوابه دعم
العراق واعتبارهم محور اقليميا دون اقفال
اي تحديات للمناخ والامن الغذائي مشاركته
ايران امر اللافت للانتباه في ظل علاقات
ايران المتوتره مع دول العربيه وغربيه وفي
ظل وجودها السياسي والامري في دول عربيه
ايضا كما ان المشاركه الفرنسيه في الاقليم
والمنطقه تثير الاهتمام عما يتطلع له همم
اليه الفرنسيون في حسب مراقبون والطريقه
التي يريدون فيها علاقاتهم مع المنطقه
العربيه والاقليم قمه بغداد اثنين تضم
عضوين جديدين هما سلطنه عمان والبحرين الى
جانبي مشاركه كل من الامارات ومصر
والسعوديه وقطر وتركيا وايران والعراق
وفرنسا من المقرر ان يحضر وزير خارجيه همم
وزير خا الاتحاد الاوروبي
ويشارك في المؤتمر امين عام جامعه الدول
العربيه احمد ابو الغيط وامي دعاء التعاون
الخليجي شكرا جزيلا لك مجدل معي مراسلتنا
في عمان